it's a fantastic time to be an la sports
fan which i am and i got to tell you
guys my story about what happened to me
yesterday okay i have to start the show
like this and it's going to lead into
our first topic about just violence at
games right now i mentioned it on an
earlier show but all you have to do is
just look at twitter pretty much every
day and you're going to see what
happened at stadiums the day before
people just feel they have the green
light to go off at games right now like
there's not going to be any
repercussions i'm talking about fans and
what they think all these tough guy fans
that are out there so yesterday a good
friend of mine who's a plastic surgeon
in beverly hills a great very very
renowned doctor said let's go to the
game so we we got some tickets last
minute we go to the chargers cleveland
game it was my friend myself and my son
dash 12 years old right so we're going
to the game first time at solfi got to
see the stadium
i describe it as it's like walking into
the future the stadium is so incredible
it is just 6.5 billion it should be the
most amazing thing is the field is about
five levels but five stories below
ground you come in ground level is the
third level the third floor you gotta go
down to get to the second and first so
it's it's unbelievable but i gotta tell
you guys it was on my mind i was
thinking okay there's going to be a lot
of cleveland fans here today no question
about it you know you never know what
fans are capable of doing they get drunk
i hope things don't get weird when you
clash when you combine two different fan
bases you throw a lot of alcohol in
there you just never know right
so i thought i hope nothing happens i
don't want to be involved in anything
like this and i don't go to games
looking for anything like this so it was
a phenomenal game did you guys see any
of this thing or what happened
47 to 42 just back and forth
what a man god we're going to talk about
him in a second so the game's over right
so the chargers score they hold baker
mayfield tried to bring the browns down
the field no luck at the end of the game
so it's over 47 to 42. i was thinking
you know what there's got to be some
history that was made today some sort of
nfl record that was broken i go let's
get a picture with the scoreboard in the
background with the score so the three
of us are just sitting there we were
amongst all kinds of browns fans they
were all over barking the whole game
feeling very very confident and secure
as they were leading so we turn around
and we're gonna do the selfie my friend
the doctor holds out the phone and he's
gonna do the picture
as we do it this guy standing behind us
in this in the row behind us yanks the
phone out of his hand
yanks it out and we're like
uh all right man hey that's kind of
funny i know the brown's last but he
will take the phone back again no you
won't he wouldn't give us the phone back
he would not give the phone back he said
you're not getting the phone back what
are you talking about give him his phone
back he goes the only way you're getting
this phone back is if you leave right
now you're not taking a picture
i mean literally it was just like that i
mean he this guy was probably 60 years
old and then you're immediately thinking
you can see how these things get
escalated right because i don't go to a
game looking for a fight i'm not a
fighter i haven't gotten into a fight
since college but i wanted to punch him
i literally did he stole his phone
that's a theft right and he was so
blazing about it and just ridiculous and
then things escalated and then
a bunch of other browns fans come in and
try to get involved and start chirping
and it it literally could have taken off
it literally like you had to hold
yourself back and say give him the phone
or you can see how this would happen how
many times i have to teach you this
lesson old man but i wanted to punch him
because he was just he deserved it and
but my son was there dash now later did
i find out if he's if he lives in
cleveland tom there's nothing that you
can do to him that god hasn't already
done so
well later i found out that part of the
reason i think he was ticked off because
dash was apparently turning around and
barking at them after every san diego
touchdown so maybe he was instant or his
la touchdown excuse me after every
charger touchdown so he was instigating
it but he literally would not give the
phone back we had to freaking
get it from him we had to take the phone
back he could have broke that phone you
know he that's so worth it so so were
had they already started circling you
with other phones like getting ready
absolutely and then this this woman who
is just so annoying she comes in there
barking at us like she had anything to
do with this and then they were just
converging on us did anybody start
yelling world star that's where you know
it's about to go down once people start
yelling world star you know it's about
to go down
i mean you go to a game and you better
be ready for something to happen you
just you just better don't don't go look
to pick a fight because you'll find one
it's those but those
those types of games more than any right
like if if you just if your team just
gets blown out you just you kind of know
but those back and forth emotional
things those highs those lows and then
when you're on the wrong side of that
you just
you've got that thing and you you got to
get it out but they're also they're
looking
to have their moments this is the west
coast in both of you guys it's like you
guys have never hopped in a car with a
bunch of your buddies and headed up to
fenway park in nothing but yankee gear
getting ready to rock and roll but you
could use part of it no that's that's a
little bit of a part of it but i i also
think that there's just a little [ __ ]
creatures man what do you think happens
when people wearing boston red sox gear
sit up in the the five dollar seats back
in the old the old pepsi bleachers yeah
but that's that's like a back road brawl
you know where you go to the the parking
lot of the local bar where you know that
they're gonna have like ufc fighting
great seats with your surgeon friend and
you're like i don't have to deal with
this plebeian nonsense it wasn't
plebeian nonsense it it's it's a a loser
looking for a fight we sh who should
have been punished
l.a san francisco you
you don't mess around you don't you
can't take a chance david if you get a
chance maybe roll some of these fight
videos that we have you can kind of see
what's been going on i don't know if you
saw that one guy get cold cocked in that
white sox astro series uh an astro fan
throws a beer on a fan in a white sox
jersey he pushes him or pushes someone
next to him and this guy just drills him
in the face twice so i do have a point
with this i just think that the lack or
the lawlessness that's going on in this
country and the lack of accountability
knowing that you can get away with
things now that you couldn't in the past
you can steal in los angeles you can you
can take everything off the shelf at
walgreens in new york city if you want
to and nothing's going to happen to you
a guy walked into a pharmacy today in
san francisco and just started taking
pills and walked out yeah pretty
outrageous i mean okay how much
this kind of goes back to the
generational thing though like
i remember almo maybe every thirsty
thursday that i played as a player
you people were getting into it so i
wonder how much of it is how many dollar
beer nights did you play dude no
outrageous alcohol plays a part in it
but also but i mean like i just back
then nobody was filming that stuff like
i wonder if we're just getting access to
this stuff now firsthand people are
looking for it people are it's always
happened i will give you that exactly
it's been going on for years i don't
know if we're more offended by it or
it's happening more frequently or if
it's just being filmed more but i do
believe there is a
a fairly high percentage of people that
go to a game now looking for it and it's
easy for them to find it and you know
it's going to get recorded it's going to
give you that five seconds of fame or
one day of fame or whatever
i don't know man but i i remember the
the malice at the palace i remember when
the when you know there was times when
hockey player was like once a year
hockey players or basketball player
would go into the stands they don't see
that anymore yeah but that would those
were very rare and that was in the 70s
or malice in the palace you know 20
years ago i'm just talking about regular
fights in the stands that are just seem
to me
more of a production like they're going
there looking to do it on purpose to get
the video and whatnot and it could have
been me on that video you think it's the
suns and four thing like this guy became
that has something to do with it as well
totally you know he was honored by the
suns yeah and barstool yeah yeah and
they actually i think did a bobble head
for him
do we have that in any of the video did
you play it yeah okay just let it roll
in the background we could see some of
these fights and but yeah so anyway that
shocked me but i was ready to roll i
really was were you ready to get you
were ready to get down well this was
last night in the chiefs game
i mean that look at this
the chiefs and the eagles got into it in
there
yeah but look at this guy he's a clown i
mean i mean is he knocked out or is he
faking it right now he's dead i mean
it's
the stuff that bothers me though is like
a bunch of drunks
up in the bleachers getting into it is
one thing but like when you're there and
you're with a 12 year old kid and like
that's the stuff that really bothers me
and that's actually what gets me fired
up like somebody some drunk guy chirping
when i'm there with my buddies that
stuff really doesn't bother me exactly
if i'm there with kids or a girl or my
mom or something that's you could just
see the mob mentality coming too and
that's what it is too these guys they
they feel bad that their team lost so
they got to get some sort of payback and
that's how they're going to do it
you have what you've got three
you've got three 15 an hour employees
per section i mean how can you possibly
i mean how can you possibly look the
it's the people that are i guess he took
a good punch man yeah he he wobbled he
didn't even go down but you're right
there's no security whatsoever there's
no repercussions at all you're in more
trouble if you step foot on the field
you know and run around for a little bit
then if you punch
go somebody look at that back in the day
how many times i i couldn't believe i
was watching the the mets documentary
every freaking game there was people on
the on the field like you know at least
that's not happening i look i don't know
oh that looks like giants fan fighting
each other i mean that turned into a
melee that was at the giants game
earlier this summer giants dodgers but
here's a prediction someone now people
have been seriously injured before but
someone's going to get killed there's no
question about it stab shot something
that escalates in the parking lot
someone's going to get seriously hurt in
the stands
it's like going through tsa to go to a
game anymore you get like padded down
you go through the the metal detector
it's insane yeah but that's true there
might not be a weapon inside the stadium
there could be in the parking lot they
go to their pickup and grab a gun but
inside here you get a couple people
stomping on somebody and pushing them
and yeah so they hit the stairs let's be
pragmatic tom what's the solution you've
been around sports for 30 years what's
the solution here's the solution you put
one of these clowns in jail
you make an example of them or at least
if you want to have some law and order
in your own stadium whether that's
dodger stadium yankee stadium fenway
wherever it is mile high doesn't matter
which team some of these guys have to
have to do some time i think that would
discourage the people you know from
trying to do it again
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
you